well you've made some changes to your
health for the new year maybe and you
don't want to blow it all while watching
the big game right so what are some gut
healthy foods you can eat instead we
caught up with a dietitian at pendulum
who has some easy swaps to share
we are what we it is the old saying
according to registered dietitian tara
carr these days she says it's more like
we are what we feed the little bugs in
our gut your microbiome it's filled with
probiotics those are living organisms
and just like you like to eat they like
to eat so when you set out to plan your
meal for super bowl sunday feed them
with fiber swap out those chips or plain
crackers for whole wheat crackers with
your dip and instead of queso make it a
yogurt-based dip forget the candies on
the table offer up some almonds instead
overall think more plant-based more
fruits and veggies maybe in addition to
those ribs that you always have what
kind of side could you add maybe
it's some you know tasty salad and maybe
you throw some great pomegranates on
there or whatever's seasonal and local
for you
i think it's great so not an all or
nothing but more just plant-based foods
in addition to maybe some of those
favorites all right you've got your
fiber probiotics and lastly don't forget
the prebiotics prebiotics that's another
um just really great gut health trick so
things like garlic maybe artichokes
maybe something asparagus on the grill
would be delicious for a super bowl
party
yes they would got to incorporate that
this weekend research of course has
linked our gut health to our overall
mood our weight our heart health and
much more